なんか気分があがらんや
うん
そういう日も
あるよね真珠
世界で恋ちゃんあそび社長です a
yeah
5日ぶりに静岡に帰ってきました大変不した大変でしたというかも静岡に帰ってこれ
ないこと自体もつらかったしいま東京で今回何していたかというとまあいろんな撮影を
しつつ
あのポケモンの竜王戦っていうのに出てたんですよ僕
スペシャルゲストとして竜王戦でどんなのかっていうとそのポケモンのゲーム
今日のゲームと
疑問のカードゲームであの日本一強いと決めるみたいな大会なんですけどそれで僕特別
ゲストとして出ることが決まってから本当にめちゃくちゃポケモン
実はやってましてなってあのあれですよあの銃を選定も本当にそこらへんの城とばなん
かちょっと強いような人はてでも全く勝てないんですよ
めっちゃ強すぎて周りがと野中北
まあ約1か月くらいから1か月ぐらい本当に多分動画以外の時間はほぼポケモンしかせ
なかったですそれくらいポケモンで時間を割くことでなんとか
竜王戦
1勝できました
はいよかったです本当に良かった政治的に勝利をつかめ誰
よかったですっという話をしたいんじゃなくてずーっとポケモー育てたり
対戦してなんか色々勉強したりしてました楽しかったですはいというわけで今日のとか
ゴミだねちょっと帰って来たばっかりで本当に何もないんで明けで暇がなくてあげれ
なかったんですけどチラ
nano universe ナノユニバースってでアレなんですよね
僕の勝手なイメージなんですけどすごいつく方気になってイメージのお店があるんです
けどそこの福袋を買いました
いやもう本当にあの
爪のご褒美ですも値段が一番5000円ですやばい皆さんご存知の通り克服売りすぎて
も服がないんでもうなんでもいいから服が欲しいということでちょっと買いましたねー
に貼ったことでオシャレでかっこいいんですけど高いんでもこういう福袋とかでしかも
かちょっと開拓でなくて気持ちがあったんで今回買わせていただきました
で儲け何か僕の買ってないだ僕の勝手な想像なんですけど僕福袋って普段
彼はないんですよなぜかというとなんで福袋っってある
だと思います
はいその通りなんですよ売れ残りなんですよ
いや知らないんですけどねその中年末までに売れ残ったものを破り屋根やべ
お店の人が矢部っつっても何とかもうねこれ得るためにスカートだ福袋たって僕勝手に
思ってるんでこんなもきっと売れ残りがあるんじゃないでしょうか
これかっこいいのがあればまず最高って言うんですけどなかった時はもうショップです
よああ
服の洋服を食べが強すぎるだけでいきます abus 米着入ってるやったらほんと
名前にマスターかっこいいんで
かっこいい服期待してるぜたまずはこれ
夫婦子が埋まっても勝ち確じゃ普通に年顔されの正体なんですけどやったやって言った
えっ
福袋ってこんなによかったっけだった
ありがとうございますやってるっだと普通にの中我々悪いなぁほんと申し訳ないくらい
なんか上の人が言ったんですけどめちゃくちゃいいとこれ
七重にば最高が打って守って本当にうれしいの次はこれだ
おおーー
オーバーチェック柄のシャツですねいや全然あり9分方法
なんか
オタクみたいになっちゃった海では次に行きましょうやはりいろんな服の
バリエーションあるというのはとても良いことなのでとても楽しみですね
どうなってんのこれそれだおっあ
なんだこれはだけこれ阪食記事だ nano universe なら絶対かっこいい
動画に間違いないと思ってるんで ou アウターポニくってみましょう
なんか磯なんか全然オタクかがなくなったらこうすることによってやっており円しか
入ってないじゃんデモやストがないこれだぜ
ねえカッコイーカッコイーカッコイイロングだけの奴や字
俺はもうあざすとし貨幣量がない
しっくりきちゃってる気がするんですけどブログだけだけどこの猫のちょっと長い感じ
が好きなんだよねったら黒普通に一番5000円以上の買い物はしてる感がある
本当に何か久しぶりにつ日間東京行ってめちゃくちゃ疲れたんですけどまぁこれで
頑張ったのしばらく東京に行かなくてよくなったんで静岡でゆっくり動画作っていけれ
ばいいなと思っております
7ヘンリー
ます
いいなぁじゃーん
[音楽]
me
あっはぁ